So a few years ago I went to go and
investigate rumors of hippos,
rogue hippos running riot it,
rural Columbia.
Now,
hippos don't naturally live in South
America.
They are from sub Saharan Africa and,
but these hippos had been transported to
Columbia by Pablo Escobar.
So Pablo Escobar,
like many powerful men,
fancied himself as a bit of a,
a Noah's Ark,
a kind of twisted,
no,
in fact,
and he wanted to build his own menagerie
at a Hacienda Napoli's,
which was his ranch where he controlled
his drug empire in between a Bogota
metagene in the,
uh,
in the Andes,
in Colombia.
And legend has it that he gathered
together this menagerie by stealing a
Russian cargo plane,
flying it,
or having it flown to Africa where he
loaded it up with loads of illegal
wildlife and it had to get it back to
Columbia before the tranquilizer animals
woke up.
Um,
and uh,
amongst this cargo of creatures was a
one male hippo that was nicknamed Lva,
Ho and three females.
And he transplanted these enormous piece
into a pond at his Hacienda.
And they loved it.
It turns out that Columbia is a hippo
paradise because actually all hippos
really want is some nice shallow water
to wallow around in and plenty of grass
to eat.
And Columbia has plenty of that and it
also has no other hippos,
so no other competition and no natural
predators.
So the hippos flourished,
uh,
in their,
in their new paradise.
And very quickly the four became eight,
became 12,
became 16.
And what happens with hippos is you have
a male who has a heart team.
So every time one of Lva,
hose sons reach sexual maturity,
he would boot him out of the pond and
that a young male hippo would then head
off in search of hippo love elsewhere.
Now,
of course in Africa,
this is completely normal.
Hippos head off from there,
their family group and young males will
go in search of hippo love,
uh,
and uh,
and,
and start their own family.
But of course in Columbia there are no
hippos out there.
So these males,
these young males are being spirited
away from Hacienda Napoli's in one of
the many,
many rivers in that part of Columbia,
which acts like sort of hippo
superhighway.
So they're sort of pinging them out into
the countryside and they arrive and they
can't find a mate.
So they,
they quite cantankerous piece the best
of times.
But these are sorts of front frustrated,
hoardy male hippos,
desperately looking for love where there
is none.
Um,
I,
I went to Columbia to investigate this
story and visited one of these rogue
males that had installed himself in a
pond next to a kindergarten.
Uh,
I've met the kids from the school who
told me that they no longer liked to
bathe in that particular pond to right.
And one of them told me about how his
grandmother had been chased by the,
uh,
love lawn beast for quite some time,
the earlier in the week.
Um,
so they,
they are,
they,
they're kind of running a mock
basically.
So,
you know,
what do you do with this situation?
You've got,
you know,
rapidly multiplying hippos.
And the extraordinary thing about what's
happening in Columbia is it's changing
their behavior because in Africa you
have this very fierce dry season,
which,
you know,
puts the brakes on hippo reproduction.
So I think they,
they reach sexual maturity,
you know,
I don't know,
I can't remember.
It's like,
Eh,
at five or seven years,
let's say.
But in Colombia they were reaching
sexual maturity significantly earlier
and having babies every year instead of
every two years.
So they were multiplying at this much
faster rate because they didn't have the
same constraints on them that they do in
Africa.
So you've got a bit of a problem.
You've got a massive invasive species
now with most invasive species,
the solution is to get rid of them
because basically they upset ecosystems
and,
and so they need to be removed.
And the problem with hippos though is
that they store in Disney movies.
So there is this sort of rogue male,
uh,
and the first one that they,
they,
uh,
they put down,
it was a public outcry.
And so they had to come up with a
different plan.
And I met with the Colombian vet who was
in charge of implementing the radical
plan B,
which was the castration program.
So Carlos Valderrama was given the
onerous task of having to cast straight
one of these rogue males.
Now this I'm sure you can appreciate as
a job that takes a fair amount of coneys
because castrating a wild male,
hippo is no easy task.
It is actually unbelievably complicated.
First of all,
I'm hippos because they've got so much
fat,
they're really hard to anesthetize
because the anesthetic dissolves in the
fat.
So even though they're enormous,
you have to get the dosage right.
They also,
when they're nervous,
they go into water,
you don't want it to pass out in the
water because it's going to drown.
Then when you finally managed to a nice,
it's Carlos sits,
me had.
And also they really,
really,
really aggressive.
And then Carlos told me that he had
decoys,
cowboys and,
and all sorts of shenanigans to try and
just to get through the anesthetics
stage.
Then the clock was on.
They had a certain amount of time in
order to complete the,
uh,
the castration.
Now,
the thing about hippos is they are the
closest relative of the hippo is the
whale.
They have internal testicles that are
buried underneath about eight inches of
skin and fat.
Not only that,
but hippo testicles have a habit of
wandering about when under threat they
can move as much as eight centimeters.
So you're looking at a blank canvas
behind which there is a moving target.
Now,
when you get in there,
they're the size of cantaloupes,
but just getting to them and working out
where to make the incision and then
managing to grab hold of these moving
melons and getting them out
was quite some task and it's apparently
it took him about six hours and uh,
it cost
well over $100,000.
So,
you know,
I think they've managed to do one more.
I subsequently,
but they're never going to.
It's just,
it's too difficult.
They're never going to be able to
castrate all the males.
That's just not going to happen.
What I think's going to happen is we're
going to have a,
a new subspecies of Colombian hippo
before too long hippopotamus Escobar,
Chris,
um,
because that's how you make a new
species you take,
you put it in isolation from its parent
species and,
and it evolves into a slightly
different,
different species.
And that's what's going to happen.
The hippo is always being quoted as
being Africa's most dangerous animal.
Now I,
I did some digging around and I've never
really been able to find out the source
of this fact,
but I can tell you,
having been charged by a hippo myself,
they are really,
really,
really dangerous.
I mean,
they,
they do kill people.
They are extremely aggressive.
They move really fast.
The,
uh,
the mail that we went to go and film the
rogue male in Columbia,
he,
uh,
we got a little bit too close and he was
in his pond and he came towards us with
such velocity that they were barrel
waves coming off his,
uh,
coming off as nosy hurtled through the
water.
Uh,
it was pretty terrifying.
I can tell you.
So the thing about hippos is they are
there,
they're really dangerous.
So
they're dangerous to humans in Columbia
who don't understand how dangerous they
are because culturally they haven't
grown up alongside hippos.
I've seen them in Disney films.
They think they're chubby and cute.
Carlos told me that this is,
this is a real issue,
but also of course they all ecosystem
engineers.
One of the things about hippos is that
they,
you know,
they're big animals,
they churn up a lot of vegetation.
They have the power to reshape their
environment and it's this reshaping of
the environment that was.
That was most alarming to cow call style
drama because he was worried that other
native species that share the rivers,
like manatees for instance,
we would suffer with hippos being
around.